this small country star behind me with a
customary crowd of idlers on the front
porch or stoop as the South Africans
call it might be found in any small
rural American community but the dirt
road that runs parallel to this small
Country Store marks the beginning of a
location in the town of Nelspruit the
African location where natives are
forced to live nelle spirit a small
mining town in the northern Transvaal
has for the past week been the focus of
the racial tension in South Africa it
started with a protest march by some 400
native women on the police station the
women have long been more militant in
their resistance to apartheid laws in
South Africa than have been their
menfolk and in Nell's break this week
the African woman has suddenly become
the focal point of resistance to the
nationalist government now sprayed on
the surface this rainy humid day looks
as quiet as that scene on that rustic
front porch of the storm but in reality
Nell spray is still tense after a week
of trouble big trouble and violence even
in South Africa I asked for permission
this morning to go inside the location
at Nell spricht and make this film we
were told that there has been trouble
there lately and they'd rather not have
any Europeans go inside this then is our
next recourse
what is behind the firm continued
refusal of African women to accept
passes well the process have been
enforced in South Africa for award very
long time among the main and it has
become very clear that the pass system
in South Africa is the basis of forced
and cheap labor now to impose such a
system up only African women is to
create hardships firstly African women
will have to produce these passes on
demand if they fail to do so they will
be arrested in the streets they will be
stopped at stations they will be stopped
as they visit one another in the
locations and if they haven't got those
passes they will be stopped and
immediately arrested and brought before
the court now African men who value they
are women just as any other people they
Olivia women say what will happen to
their children
ladies why was the black sash formed in
the first place well the black sash was
formed in the first place because the
nationalist government introduced the
Senate bill into Parliament it was a
bill to expand the size of the Senate to
almost double the size of its original
size and you fear that this would do one
well we felt that it was a legal trick
or we didn't know whether it was legal
then but we felt it was a piece of
trickery and against the spirit of the
Constitution what has been the official
government reaction to your protests of
Mourning the government have ridiculed
us for mourning they don't understand or
say they don't understand why women
should stand mourning a constitution
they think we would be much better
staying at home and looking after our
children and obviously you won't
disagree well we think that we do look
after our children we feel very much
that this is looking after our children
because after all it's the future of our
children we're worried about if I had no
children I don't think my interest would
be nearly as keen in this connection
it's been said that the South African
woman the white woman occupies a
privileged position in the world because
of the abundance of servants and cheap
labor here wouldn't this somehow
conflict with what you're trying to do
arouse women to protest yes it does I
think that we are very privileged women
in that we are not tied to the kitchen
sink because as with so many women are
in other parts of the world and I think
that is all the more reason why women
should play their full part in the
duties of an individual in a democracy
we feel that democracy cannot work
unless every individual knows what her
obligations are in the democracy but I
think you're putting the standard of
morals very low if you reckon that we
are going to go on supporting our party
just in order to keep our servants one
final question
being very realistic how soon can you
hope to take off that black sash
well I'm afraid not in our lifetime by
far the largest church denomination in
the Union of South Africa is the Dutch
Reformed Church with a membership of
almost two million white and non-white
members with us this morning is Domini
Adrienne Berger Secretary of the Federal
Council of Dutch Reformed churches and
editor of diva lector the Transvaal
church magazine domine Berger you
believed in apartheid as a way of life
yes I do why in South Africa why is that
sir because the race which is in this
estate of development is by far in the
majority had and numerically of course
they are much stronger and because also
I believe that it is according to God's
will that the white race which is in the
majority in this country should be
preserved and also everything we have
done in the last 300 years and built up
in the church and in the state should be
preserved and not be swallowed up by and
I wouldn't say in theory a race because
it I don't believe it is an inferior
race but a lesser a race which is in a
lesser state of development that's all
you sir have been fighting a fight for a
long time that requires as I see it a
great deal of quiet sustained courage
don't you ever have a sense of futility
of uselessness well there come times of
course when one does feel that you're
frustrated in what you're trying to do
it yet on the other hand there's a great
thrill in it
perhaps you can answer this one question
that's intrigued me for a long time
there are I am sure devout believers in
apartheid were also devout Christians
can these two apart hating Christianity
in Europe in Yin be reconciled I'm quite
sure that they cannot one of the
mystifying things to me is how anybody
who claims to be a Christian can be a
disciple of apartheid do you find any
conflict between apartheid and
Christianity no certainly not
as a matter of fact our Dutch Reformed
churches are doing much more for the
Christianization of this of the
non-white people in this country than
any other Protestant Church in this
country and anywhere in Africa we as
Christians believe in the development of
the non-white people and we certainly
try to develop them as far as possible
by building their churches giving
subsidizing them in their church work
and we are also trying to give them
leadership where they want it and our
experience is that these people prefer
to be left in their own churches as a
matter of fact there are nine different
non white churches belonging to the
Dutch Reformed Church amongst the
non-white people and they prefer that
there are instances when we come
together on a higher level in
conferences and sometimes also in their
churches we often come there as white
people to visit them and there are also
instances where we even have communion
with him can you foresee any eventual
end to apartheid in the Dutch Reformed
Church the Dutch Japan Church does not
practice Apothic because we believe that
integration is religiously around or
ethically wrong certainly not in theory
we have nothing against integration it's
only a matter of
tickle policy in this country now for
this for this moment if conditions
should change this or any other
practical policy could also be changed
something is there any corollary do you
think between American segregation and
South African apartheid no I think well
in one sense I think it's all part of a
royal pattern I think that the white
race as a whole find it extremely
difficult to realize that they can no
longer dominate the whole world but the
thing that encouraged me in America is
that in spite of what has happened that
is happening the general trend is in
entirely the opposite direction what is
happening in South Africa the user
believed that there's any possibility
now or in the immediate foreseeable
future of large-scale violence in South
Africa no there are a lot of people who
seem to be very fearful that it may
happen but for my part I am convinced
that all the responsible leadership of
the India among the Africans and Indians
is determined at all cost to prevent
violence if they can possibly do so
mr. prince lil what is the basic
philosophy underlying apartheid as a way
of life we Europeans who've lived in
this country for more than 300 years
have come to a conclusion which is
strange to some people in the Western
world namely that the peoples of Africa
and so the bunch of people of South
Africa have a beautiful civilization of
their own which is worth preserving
there are many facets of the
civilization for instance the social
warmth of the Bantu people's which we
Westerners can rightly envy them now we
also have a peculiar waste and
adaptation to Africa therefore we can
say that the bonded peoples are a flower
and the Western peoples are a flower
each with a beauty of its own I've heard
them in the South Africa of today you
can be classified as coloured simply by
looking colored is this in point of fact
true well I can give you a better which
may seem amusing that all the
humiliating incidents had occurred in
our country when the department of
census started to declassifying people
the old people of the times in the
mornings out of the bus queues and took
him up to the native commissioner's
office and some of the tits applied to
tell a man that he was not colored was
trying to profit from 3za and the
Comstock is told you at Keffer and other
people lose know this with a bit flat
but older you're not a colored mister
Prinsloo as you are no doubt aware most
criticism of apartheid outside the Union
is based largely on moral grounds for
example the morality of separate
residential areas in the cities of the
Union pass laws lack of voting rights
and so on how would you reply to lists
as far as residential areas are
concerned the practical situation is
that until about ten years ago there
were no residential areas for urban
bunch of people it is only in the last
few years that such areas were set aside
on a plan basis
and developed at a terrific pace as you
can see all around you this housing
scheme which now houses more than 30,000
urban Bantu who work in Victoria was at
their plain a mere four years ago I
think that is a complete answer to the
so-called immorality of separate
residential areas in the political field
we are creating an outlet in that we are
proclaiming bon to authorities in all
the major boundary areas of the Union we
have already brought into life more than
three hundred such authorities where one
two who have the inclination the
training and the moral courage to start
developing their own people can do so
with all possible assistance from the
government if the government convinced
that the African wants and accepts
apartheid as a development policy for
obvious reasons many opponents of this
policy tried to influence the bunch of
people in the other direction and like
all new philosophies like all new piece
of policies we had to put our case to
the bunch of people and I can safely say
today that the Bantu people are
accepting the policy of self-development
which essentially is a part with a part
it essentially is in an ever increasing
temple I feel confident that the Bantu
leadership of Africa rural and urban
will by the turn of next year show in a
most market way that they are satisfied
that this policy leads to their
salvation is to knock way mr. Prince Lou
of the Native Affairs Department told me
in Pretoria this week that the African
accepts and wants apartheid as a stage
of development you sir agree well it's a
privileged information in mind and I can
claim to be slightly more informed than
mr. Prince knows because I live among
the African and I am an African cannot
be quite correct at all the other than
people are realizing
apartheid means nothing else but
oppression and exploitation to them if
mr. Prince close contention is correct
then why do we have these on the unrest
in the countryside in the most backward
areas of the country mr. Prince laws
information is also correct then why do
we have these deposition of chiefs why
do we have the government agents moving
around in the urban in the rural areas
to find out what is going on if the
people who are so contented to audit
within the net design to have so many
agents watching over them I have had
such hatred for every white man that I
came across from the earliest days that
I could remember but with the passing of
years and having had understanding of
fundamental things in life I have been
able to overcome that but I can assure
you that that was one of the greatest
struggles that I had to undergo with
myself
mr. Payton it's a tall order in a big
question but if you can do it how would
you characterize the emotional climate
of South Africa today well I think
probably it's hotter than it's been for
a long time
in what way in regard to its race
problem yeah you know got to the
relations between the groups
I suppose the relations between the
english-speaking and the
afrikaans-speaking Rupe are cold mm-hmm
in view of the daily indignities
humilities and in some cases actual
hardships economic and otherwise that
the non-european is subjected to because
of the apartheid laws do you ever wonder
at or a puzzle that a non-european can
ever be civil to a white well that
taught often occurs to me mr. McCutcheon
because you know we have many
non-european friends and sometimes you
do wonder how they can go on liking you
you know do you mr. Payton fear in the
foreseeable future any widespread
violence in South Africa well that's
what everyone fears it's not just me
it's no I mean whether you're a white
nationalist or whether you're a black
man or whether you're english-speaking
whether you're an Indian I think all of
us have that fear that violence one day
will it will be violent one day mr.
Payton I read a quote by you once not so
long ago in which if I can recall it you
said you might hesitate to rush forward
to help an African injured on the street
is that the essence of what you said you
recall it oh yes this letters quoted did
not book drum by Anthony Simpson I think
I I think I was 1948 I think I what a
bit reticent and I heard pointer I was
really trying to make was that in this
kind of race mad world in which we live
that a white man even if he went to the
assistance might well hesitate before
you did I think that that might you
might find that in many parts of service
the southern states too there's been
much talk here I underst
and of passive resistance as a matter of
actual fact however can the African the
Indian or the colored in his present
economic state financially afford a long
period of general strikes or passive
resistance
I would imagine no no you haven't got
powerful trade unions you have built up
great funds but nevertheless I mean
there are significant things happening
you know you've heard of the bus boycott
yes I have here in Johannesburg
there was an example where people by
their determination forced the not only
the bus companies but also the
government to retreat mr. Payton you
loved this country very much despite
what's been happening here for the past
few years what's happening here today
how does it make you feel when you are
aware that your beloved country is the
subject of so much worldwide
condemnation well I see I have so many
friends in other countries mr. McCutchen
and I know that I don't I'm not the
subject of their condemnation and I must
say that makes it much easier for me to
bear see but I understand well the
reasons for this condemnation and much
of it is justified but it doesn't
personally make me unhappy except I
would say this that when I go overseas I
meet people who start condemning South
Africa that very often I find myself my
blood beginning to get warmer and I find
myself defending it even defending the
government in fact in what one examples
for example well I can give you one very
good example I'm remember sitting next
to a fellow at dinner in San Francisco
and he said to me this dr. Milano's must
be a very vicious old man and I said the
message you know that's not true
actually dr. Malone is in his own
particular white world he is quite a
nice old gentleman but when it comes
into the world of rice when rice
morality becomes his supreme morality
which it is that's what apartheid is
it's race morality then he will take any
step whatsoever to ensure the supremacy
of his own tea
in other words mr. McCutchen if you make
your own survival your supreme moral
value and you're capable of almost
anything even though you're a nice old
man mr. pavements magnificent in this
country is physically aren't there those
who find it difficult if not impossible
to continue living in this climate of
fear oh yes ELISA I know what number of
people who have finally decided to leave
the country perhaps for their own sakes
perhaps for the sake of their children
this question of apartheid has been
placed so far as of don european is
concerned so purely on a question of
color that theoretically if black man
should come into power in south africa
is it not possible that the pendulum
might swing the other way is there any
justification to fear that the white man
would in truth be driven into the sea
well that's a question that that lots of
people ask and no one can answer mr.
McCutcheon I would say that amongst the
African people there are some of them
who have under these ended under this
present dispensation and the
dispensations before it will come to
hate any kind of color discrimination
whatsoever I find it hard to believe I
mean I don't say the feeling of revenge
will be entirely absent but I find it
hard to believe that they could set up a
state in which their whole aim would be
to discriminate against white people I
find that difficult yes master yes yes
laws
ladies and gentlemen you know that the
series of talks that we have been giving
here have been talks designed to
describe to you how government works and
you've had torques recently on
government and law in general and also a
description of how the parliamentary
machine works in South Africa
don't you think the Chairman that is the
field of cultivating the mind alert of
the little things people is more work
for the rebuttal to do their time to
come and try to cultivate the mind of
the African people because I think we're
capable of winded on your own self if
not any advice from any angle whatsoever
let us understand that here in South
Africa and in fact in the whole of
Africa we are dealing with the National
quest and Africa is not very secure and
disrespect nearly every country had had
it let its national problems and they
are always solved by the people
according to the myth the needs of the
majority of the people in the particular
countries concerned I have at the
present moment we don't even have the
right of self yes
it's printable we could define a term
that's intrigued me since you started to
use it you have said repeatedly that the
non-european is different from the
European now in your mind is different
synonymous with inferior I think it is a
generally accepted fact today that the
non-european is at the lowest stage of
development and in honor of the Advanta
European that does not mean to say that
they are inherently inferior
circumstances amongst which they have
grown up and grow their whole cultural
background and everything their whole
diet which would lead to physical
physiological changes in their own
nervous system would all lead to a
general idea of the inferiority amongst
you in your compare original European
with the European but I do not believe
that the non-european assets is
inherently inferior is merely at a much
lower state of development at the
present better but will they take up
their - yes boss yes yes both
yes balls yes
yes but
to you as a man of sensitivity and
intelligence ever get used to a party
and what it does to you I'm a state not
because it continuously affronts me I am
forced to be indignant about it I cannot
get used to it
I must resist it
you